welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Chamberlain Chamberlain lets her
look Alex hey Gabrielle off I segrand
mas no he was an IM when it was some
years ago on the as you see i play this
is a very he's a veteran dices he player
okay let's see we got a philly dorm a
for early 84 i don't know i'm not sure
of a five from why does a threat here
and now d 5 is the way it is played
normally but ok this is also possible ok
yeah i'm not an expert on this
quince is seven probably next not sure
about bishop fa dia that's a very
routine move but sometimes it's also
good to get the night to g6 like Quincy
79 f 896 yeah the Queen to see for this
is a funny idea huh yeah Quincy for
maybe d hive but
hmm wow this looks like really this
looks very is like very simple I mean I
mean I mean it looks like so simple that
it shouldn't give white anything but
maybe I'm I'm wrong here okay let's
trade some stuff what is why playing
here for trading or maybe just the trade
and take on f6 however that's very
little okay
here I can also just play Bishop e7 here
why not maybe just do that all right
sorry about my voice IAM not sure what
it is too much too long too many
coaching sessions today are I don't know
okay so I'm just trading stuff here
Knight to f5 yeah maybe maybe keep this
under control so that I can take it
neither five I can just capture and not
not very air not not great but still
it's very very solid ya need to keep
them d 7 kappa jack now that's not very
nice some very annoying pressure on my
position I don't really see something
huge for him but
who
going for Bishop c5 maybe under the
right circumstances
it's it's tough I need to think need to
get some more some more space yeah like
this maybe blue Bishop c5 is and now i
can play Bishop c5 I think takes takes I
will get you will get to see for just in
time I have to prepare that Bishop
Bishop c5 now is an idea
I'm sure really unsure about it if this
was a good idea or not night on g6 would
be nice oh my i'm sorry about this and
really a problem or really know where
this is nothing i don't think that what
can can hope for anything here current
rate okay so queen king here yeah those
sound light squares that's not good but
still I don't think time or anything
this much going on a g5 I don't know is
probably and I can't play that thing
there are also some ideas to to play
active moves I'm not totally we'd used
to passive defense IAM if and yeah
whatever yeah this is I was thinking
that this could be a problem Jack nights
you form this this an issue I don't know
I don't have time this is the problem
not the position I have no time
and the draw I will play on time here to
pickle claw okay no gain yeah okay this
is actually actually right yeah it's a
wrong wrong color wrong wrong corner I
look for the bishop yeah hmm we I think
the Queen trade is really a mistake for
white you should have kept queens on I
don't think that this this can be be any
sort of idea the question is can I do
something Bishop is a clumsy PCM I had
the computer gives c4 is clearly better
for black this is a trap piece poo I
didn't think about that at all Wow very
simple idea winning the bishop White has
a hard time to to do anything against it
huh this is of course much worse in
comparison yeah and this is now opening
up to White's advantage maybe yeah yeah
that said sets now the H bonus is strong
but he played some weird moves here b3
as possible this is what I had expected
but here we are we are just I just have
a draw him as was probably bit luckier
odd but ok I could have trapped his
bishops well ok thanks for watching